Eric Tay it is the what third day of
playing and you have beaten the division
yeah I've been campaign now I I haven't
as many people on the Twitter as I said
I haven't really beaten the entire game
I haven't done everything but I have at
least gotten to the point where it's
like ended cool so yeah your level 30
mm-hm and we are gonna take a look at
the end game and what is all about what
do you do when you get this far so
there's a couple things you can do of
course you can finish your side missions
or continue to build up your and develop
your base to you know hundred percent so
you unlock all your perks and talents
and then on top of that once you hit 30
you're then given the daily missions
which you have to unlock at 30 and then
of course you can still continue to
grind the dark zone and then of course
you're chasing high-end weapons
essentially right where a high-end gear
rather which we can take a look at
because once you hit 30
I believe this guy will show up the
special vendor here's the special gear
vendor here there is and yeah hot damn
those are purple and gold yeah and so
here is that new currency those the
Phoenix dollars Phoenix Dollars are
earned primarily through the daily
missions and you can hopefully try to
get through some of them to get the
Phoenix bucks you can also buy you know
recipes blueprints to create your own
high-end stuff armor and weapons as well
as no mods now if we take a look at the
map I have one daily mission left so
again these daily make sure pop up at
level 30 yep straight up so that's it so
you have 30 daily missions that's your
new life yeah so there were three that
were available to me
I'm guessing on a daily basis and to me
there were three different tiers almost
the first tier was kind of like your
easy beginner you're getting some dark
zone dollars from that then you had like
this mid tier one that was a bit more
challenging I sold out both of them it
did take me a little bit of time to do
the mid tier one because all the enemy
AI are essentially elites they all have
armor and they all take a lot more to
kill them yeah and they're more spongy
and their level 30 as a Walker I'm
show you the high-end tier one which
says you should have four members in a
party at level 30 is it almost safe to
say that the divisions daily mission for
player daily missions are almost like
raids I mean are they close to it
it I mean in the current game I guess
you could argue that it's like that but
really it's just a kind of like harder
to your mission that you can do with
your buddies and you're gonna need
buddies to do but if you're talking in
terms of destiny ish it's maybe like a
nightfall like you're one bolt except
it's daily instead of weekly but it's a
harder mission that you do to try to get
that really good loot because you are
guaranteed a piece of high-end gear if
you beat it and you get more Phoenix
dollars from doing this mission but I'm
gonna show you these level 32 guys now
and watch this is a headshot right yeah
it's that did a lot but it took off one
sliver of his armor and they're lighting
me up already I died a couple times just
trying this just to see if I could solo
it yesterday
yeah and they killed me in about three
shots or so this is definitely a damn
good the other thing you can do other
than you know just your typical daily
mission once you beat on or you know
once you can get through some of them is
you can continue to grind the dark zone
if you haven't already because the dark
zone you need to be level fifty dark
zone level to use and buy the high-end
stuff which is insane because I'm only
level like eleven now because I barely
played damn yeah
granted I think it'll go faster if
you're in a group but they're pretty
spongy solo and it's pretty dangerous
it's definitely doable it's just more
time-consuming right yeah I just wanted
to show you one more vendor before we
left if I could find him yeah he's back
here and so you can also buy high-end
weapons except they are ridiculously
priced like five hundred thousand
dollars ridiculous and I haven't found a
good farming system yet like you can get
10,000 credits or something or like
15,000 from beating you know the
missions and the like the hard mode
missions maybe you just do all the
missions on hard again but that doesn't
seem very efficient like I don't know
who is gonna save up to buy this I guess
you could sell a bunch of your melon
right it's like one or the other either
either you I I want to say it either
your your D junking or dismantling or
your selling right like you you should
probably pick a goal yeah it's just
really hard because you know you can fly
you know those recipes from the other
guy the specials gear vendor and he has
you know recipes to make high-end ACR is
a case you know m1 A's and you're gonna
need some of those parts you know and
how expensive are those um they're well
they're 100 something Phoenix bucks
which is something you have to buy but
I'm just saying you know you it might be
faster to break stuff down because like
you said you can you can convert write
stuff at the crafting station and that's
what I'm gonna ultimately do right like
I yeah got this high-end pistol yeah
lovely pistol the Damascus when I picked
it up I get to Damascus that's got to be
an assault rifles like oh it's a pistol
and I could make this if I did the
conversion right I need five high-end
parts but I could do that by converting
a bunch of my weapon parts I had I can
make ten high-end weapon parts right now
it's just that I don't have a good
high-end weapon recipe so I do have to
get that from the dark zone or from the
special gear vendor who you know both of
them are grinds all right well that is
just a little taste of the end game
thanks Eric for grinding away to kind of
show or give us a better idea of what
that's about
yeah no problem it's a the life I live
the loop drives me man and I'm gonna try
to get some high-end stuff so we can
show some of that off I just have to get
the grinding so I think I'm gonna go do
that in after I make this video sounds
great okay thanks very much Eric and for
all of your division news and content
she's gotta be in stock
[Music]